hello welcome back to material from Mass
gravity guide today we're gonna look at
episode 3 part 2 strategies and today
we're gonna talk about the jobin
strategy and the Green Tech strategy
okay so now let's talk about UV Intex
the rest of the strategies here are
pretty much extensions of the card
strategy if that makes sense but for
good measure I'll just go through them
quickly Joven text is it really strategy
I mean if you don't get Joven amplifiers
can it really be considered a strategy
to be fair this is more like Synergy but
you know a lot of people like jovians
let's talk about them if you want to see
game example on the mass app where I go
for Jovi Intex and I'm set on systems
then you can check out episode 19. so
Joey Intex is a strategy that can work
in both short and long games but I think
attempt to favor long games a little bit
more because then you have more time to
get the jovians jovians are great in
Greedy two-player games for instance
because it's a part of the card strategy
naturally if you play a million cards
then you're bound to find a lot of
jovians it can also work in five play
games but it's a bit more risky the
thing about the Jobing cards they're
really expensive they're they can't
invite you to have a big engine a lot of
titanium production and sometimes in
five player game the game is just over
by Generation 7 and you really don't
even have time to play your amplifier
because it's just so expensive in these
short games Saturn system is a perfect
cooperation if you want to go for
jovians because every time a jovian Tech
is played you get one Mega credit
production and also you get a titanium
production which is nice for playing
these expensive job index and the funny
thing Saturn system is actually I think
slightly better in five player games but
it's good regardless of player now but
the reason it's better in five player
games maybe is that then you have four
opponents who might also play in sub
Jovian sometimes so you get a lot of
free stuff but you can also make an
argument that is good in two or three
player games because when the games are
longer and more greedy then people are
more likely to play jovians Let's talk
about Joven amplifiers there are four
Joven amplifiers in the vanilla game and
funnily enough they're not actually
adding more amplifiers in the expansions
so you only have these four and yes I am
counting terraforming enemies as an
amplifier I mean if you play this cast
as your last job intake then it
literally is an amplifier I think Joe
Van amplifiers are pretty well known a
lot of people favor these and this is
like the set collection of this game it
could be really strong like sometimes
you get 60 points and jovians alone or
something and that's a lot of points so
it's really worth noting however it's
not always these cards are good I think
people just oh it's a German amplifier I
have to keep it I also made this mistake
with the starting hand where I started
with iron mining Industries like oh it's
an amplifier I have to keep this I
shouldn't have so sometimes it's a
little bit of a bait so basically it's a
little bit out of your control like you
can decide to start the game alright I'm
gonna go for Jovian text today but then
ultimately it comes down to whether or
not you pick up any amplifiers because
without amplifiers you're not getting so
much out of your jovians in fact all the
Joven cards are pretty expensive the
Joven Tech itself costs something on
these cards so this means that if you're
not getting a Joven amplifier then
usually the joking cards are actually
pretty bad so how many VP does an
amplifier actually give you it's really
hard to answer this because sometimes
it's like one point or sometimes it's
like 12 points so if you're having a
good game and this is like maybe even
generous but if you're having a good
game I think a drove an amplifier on
average could give you like six VP and
if you get this that's totally fine and
if you manage in your game to get this
many Joven text then it's perfect then
it's really good actually so how many
joins would you have to have for this to
be worth it so let's do the math here
tier two what assassin for you to go to
file
so if we say that in the late game a
victory point is worth 8 Mega credit and
the cast costs three for example IO
mining Industries this is like the most
expensive of them and that's because it
comes with a little engine but if you
get six jovins this is worth it because
then it adds up to 48 and that's more
than the 44 the card costs but if you
only get 5 trillions and you play Iron
mining Industries in the last generation
it's actually not that good it's a
little bit lower than the average but
then again if you play i o mining
Industries sooner in the game it's of
course back to being really good because
then you also get the engine building
capabilities of these cards then we got
gaining The Colony if we set a victory
point to be eight in the last generation
well then you only need three Jovian to
actually make this card work and you
need four German tags to make water
import from Europa worth it and
terraforming again image you kind of
need five German tags to make this work
if you are playing certain systems of
course jovians are better because then
you get one Mega credit production every
time a job intact is put into play and
then you might be inclined to play your
amplifiers a little bit sooner but even
with the plus one Mega credit production
I still think you should consider are
waiting before playing the amplifiers
usually you play these amplifiers in the
last generation except fire mining
industry so usually you have better
things to spend your mega credit on than
just playing an amplifier early just for
the plus one Mega trade it's not that
good job in amplifier should be played
in the last generation except of course
form iron mining Industries also there
are a few other exceptions we'll talk
about those so I O mining Industries is
actually kind of cool because this card
can be played in any phase of the game
depending on the situation in the early
game you can play this card as soon as
possible because it gives you a lot of
money income like two titanium
production two Mega credit production I
mean really what you should do you
should play it as soon as it makes sense
for you maybe in the early game you had
better engine building options available
to you in that case you would wait but
mostly you want to play this as soon as
possible if that makes sense sometimes
it could even be worth it to just pass
an entire generation just to complete
time mining Industries in the Next
Generation so really it comes down to do
you have any better engine building
options available to you if yes then you
wait before you play Iron mining
Industries and I'm talking about the
early to mid game of course because in
the mid to late game you really want to
favor Aya mining Industries over like
Mega credit production in general
because then you're also more focused on
getting VP and iron mining Industries
like we talked about it can give you a
lot of VP but like we mentioned you kind
of need a few job in tags for this card
to be worth it at least from a VP point
of view in the late game if you play
this in the last generation of course
you're only playing this card to get all
the VP but then like we talked about
just to play this card only for the VP
that is really expensive so you need to
have at least six job in tags for this
to actually be worth it but it's not
even like this this is just the average
values really what it comes down to what
are your available plays in the last
generation if your base player to play
Iron mining Industries go for it if
there's another player that will give
you even more victory points do that
like maybe you could take the landlord
from somebody or something that's even
more impactful than my mining Industries
you just have to do the math in the last
generation that's all I'm saying then we
got ganymy colony in 9 out of 10 games
this should be played in the late game
preferably in the very last generation
of the game possible exceptions if you
lose actually have 1 million titanium
you can't consider playing a little bit
before if you have immigrant City
technically yes it will give you like
one Mega credit production if your
satellite Galilean weigh station the
same it could be something you consider
but really it should only be if you have
like too much titanium otherwise this
one Mega credit production is not really
what should do it for you but sometimes
it is worth it because the thing is you
want to be playing this card sooner or
later so if you play it a little bit
before and you get one Mega credit
production it could be worth it also
depends how much discount you have
really what it comes down to is do you
have other better engine building
options available to you if yes then
play Academy colony in the last
generation just for the week p and
finally there's of course also the mayor
Milestone to consider I mean once again
it's really not that important but it
could come into play that you really
want the mere Milestone but you just
have to be really careful you don't get
baited because playing enemy Colony just
to get the media Milestone that's like a
big hit on your economy especially when
we're talking about the early to mid
game when it's usually the time that the
mere Milestone is going to be then we've
got water import from Europa and that
are the same games same you want to play
this in the very last generation in the
late game now once again if you have a
lot of titanium then this card could
actually be okay to play a bit sooner
the thing is you can also spend titanium
to use this action so for 12 Mega
Critters or for titanium you could build
the water so if you have like a million
titanium then of course you want to play
this a bit earlier just don't get baited
into thinking that it's like really good
value because when you think about it a
TR is worth eight and then the placement
bonus of water is worth around four if
you're generous and that adds up to 12
so that's exactly what you're getting
with this card so even after you build
this expensive card for 25 Mega crits
then you just get the action for
building a water for 12 and that's
literally exactly what a water is worth
so it's not that good so just be careful
you just don't spend 25 Mega credits
just to completely mess up your own
ninja because you think this card should
be used to make water it's really not
the point of this card it's really rare
actually that this card should be used
to build the water usually you should
play this in the last generation only
because of the VP capabilities but of
course it could be that you have some
water Synergy so water is a little bit
better for you in that case I don't know
it's still questionable but you know
it's something to consider it could also
be that you have killed farming or
penguins in your hand and in that case
it could be kind of nice for you to
build some water especially if you're
thinking about building the standard
project aquifier for 18 Mega credits
well then obviously this is a better
choice but then is it really because
then you also spend 25 Mega credits just
so you can get water a bit cheaper so it
still has to be a consideration and of
course if you are going for the
terraformer Milestone you're really
close to your opponent then building
water makes sense then we got
terraforming Guinea bead in 9 out of 10
games this should also be played in the
last generation but terraforming animate
is actually one of the fun cards because
if you're having a literal God game you
can also use this card in the mid game
for its engine building capabilities but
to be fair this almost never happens I
mean German attacks are pretty expensive
so when do you really have enough
driving tax played this early on and on
top of that you have to play this really
expensive card just to get engine it
almost never happens but when it does it
actually it's really fun I think it
would have to be like six plus job in
text you need to have with this so on
the plus side if we're still in the mid
game and you manage to play this with
six Adobe index then you're getting six
TR and that's actually engine that's
like six Mega credit production right so
that actually does matter but on the
other hand if you later in the game pick
up even more Joven text then you kind of
feel a little bit bad that you played
this a bit sooner but it's not that
simple what you have to consider is is
it better for you to get the mega credit
you got for playing this in the mid game
or is it better for you to get the let's
say plus two victory points because you
picked up another two drove in Tech by
the end of the game once again if you're
fighting for the terraformer Milestone
this card can actually be a lot of fun
to just play and just snatch that from
one of your opponents but for this to be
worth it like I said you really have to
have like five or six job Intex it also
works with a benefactor but that is the
award so if you're fighting for the
benefactor then you still play terraform
again in the very last generation
because then it's like a big surprise
Factor oh he's beating me in
benefactor I did not expect that so when
should you go for Joven text if you get
Joven amplifiers you consider going for
juven Tech you can also collect job in
tags and just hope that you'll get a
German amplifier later on if you do
decide to go for Joven text maybe you
have a Joven amplifier in your hand then
you should really consider keeping most
German tax and I say most is actually
not all German tags that are worth it to
keep even if you're going for it it
depends like on the titanium production
and is your economy strong enough to
build all of these Jovian maybe you have
something better you can do so it's not
like a given you keep all your intakes
just because you have an amplifier and
regardless even if you're not going for
the Jovian amplifier and the Jovian
strategy then you should still play the
Good Jovian text some Jovian tags are
pretty strong cards even without the
amplifiers but to be honest most of the
drawing cards are actually pretty bad if
you do not get a Joven amplifier so most
of the bad driving cars you only play if
you hope to get a German amplifier or
maybe you have a German amplifier in
your hand already so like we mentioned
jogan amplifiers has been part of this
also if you're set up systems then of
course you're a little bit more inclined
to go for Joven text in general and also
if you're playing vanilla I think this
might surprise some people but actually
the Jovian tags and the Joven strategy
is actually better if you're playing
only vanilla for example if you're
playing on the mass app it's actually
only vendela and also pre-loose if you
bought that one there's a little bit of
cards and preloos but not that many so
if you're playing on the master or if
you're playing only with the base game
then it's actually better to go for
Jovian techs because the chance to get a
Joven amplifier is bigger in vanilla
because there are only four Joven
amplifiers and even with all expansions
they added they don't add more Joven
amplifiers so they're only the four of
them no matter how many expansions you
play with so if you're playing with all
of the expansions maybe you have twice
as many cards as if you're only playing
with vanilla so this is why it's a
little bit more likely to get a job in
amplifier if you're playing vanilla
worth noting I'm only talking about
amplifiers here Joe Intex in general a
kind of just as likely to get if you're
playing vanilla or with all the
expansions because what stronghold game
does is able time they release an
expansion they add in the same
percentage of job intacts to the new
expansion so I'm not talking about Job
Intex I'm only talking about the four
driven amplifiers these four cards
you're more likely to get if you only
play vanilla of course if you're a card
Pro then there's a high likelihood of
you getting an amplifier and you really
need these amplifiers to make these
joins worth it this is what I mean when
I say that the drawing strategy is
usually better in two or three player
games because they're kind of longer in
terms of generations because if you're
playing a five player game and the game
is over already on Generation 7 it's
actually really hard to make the Joven
strategy work because the job in tags
are so expensive and you just don't have
enough time to collect and play all of
these expensive job in tags finally
let's talk about green Tags I'm talking
about animal attacks micro attacks plant
tags now green text Synergy can be
really good so I'm calling it a strategy
here but is it really a strategy maybe
it's more like Synergy I mean you can
make the argument that this entire video
is all about Synergy and not strategies
but no matter how your slice it green
tags can be very powerful so we should
talk about it now green text so that is
a mid to late game straight it's better
for long games and there are a few
reasons for this first of all all of the
Green Tech amplifiers is like catch kind
of playing the mid game secondly they
all like VP right so VP cards you
usually won't play in the last half of
the game you don't really play a lot of
green tanks in the early game they don't
give you engine and usually you can't
even play them because of their crime
and stuff like this and finally animal
and micro cards are a big part of this
and these cards just get better the
longer the game goes because mostly
animals and microbes are action cards
which means that every generation you
can keep adding microbe animals to these
cards which means that if you get all of
this up and running you really want to
play the long game because every single
generation you just get free VP from all
the action cards animals and microbes
and stuff like this if you're getting
like four free victory points every
generation it's really hard for anyone
to actually compare with this so it's
definitely in your interest to let the
game drag out as long as possible and
this is also why I think the green text
in general are like part of the card
strategy because you want the game to go
low and naturally when you're playing a
lot of cards when you seeing a lot of
cars drawing a lot of cards you're going
to get a lot of green text energy and
the more green text energy you can get
the better and also keep in mind the
green text can increase in value so when
you play these green tags it's also
really important for instance Advanced
ecosystem it's it's a card that gives
you three victory points usually you
play this in the last generation because
it only gives VP and on top of that it
has three green tags and these green
tags can be really valuable if you wait
before you play them so for example if
you have Royal enhancers decomposers and
ecological Zone all of a sudden instead
of giving you three VP this is like 5vp
and three planes and this value is like
insane so if you think about it 5vp for
11 Mega credits that's way better value
than you're getting from a jovian
amplifier usually and Green Tech Synergy
is also kind of cool because it can kind
of turn bad cards into good cards so for
instance we got adaptive Legion this
card I'm not so crazy about I think it's
one of the weaker cards in the set like
imagine if this card did not have a plan
tag it would be literally unplayable so
remember the card costs three so for 2
12 Mega credit you get one plant
production that is horrendous especially
considering that okay you can play this
in the early game but you don't really
want to because in the early game you
need money in common then you play this
in the mid game and uh the value is bad
man yeah so I'm really sorry but this is
not a good car however what if you can
actually use this plant tag for
something useful maybe you have insects
or nitrogen-rich asteroid or something
like this then all of a sudden this card
could be worth it so this is like one of
the beauties of this game that the text
matters so much in this game so all of a
sudden a bad card like this can all of a
sudden become good if you have a lot of
green text energy well to put it in a
different way a way that you sue must
understand well there you go Sumas like
memes right actually maybe Boomers also
like memes I don't know are memes
unpopular no they're still popular I
think the kids are really down with the
memes these days so maybe it's for all
of us this is for all of us so instead
of adapted Legend plus M6 it could also
be like adapt unleash plus ecological
Zone but even this might not be worth it
because then you're just getting like
another half a point still questionable
but you get my point at that solution
bad card but if if you have green text
energy it could be a good card so if
you're going for this green text Synergy
Shenanigans which cards should you
actually be looking out for meat
Industries this card is amazing it could
also be the GMO contract which is a
thermal card or it could also be this
topsoil contract which is a promo card I
actually thought there was a Pathfinder
car so this is why they didn't include
it initially but this is like the same
idea if you play microbes or if you play
Animals you get a little bit of stuff
and these cards are like perfect with
the card strategy where you also go for
green text because like we talked about
this is like how you go God mode if you
get a little bit of stuff every time you
play some of these so every time you do
some of this it's like a big ingredient
of how to go God mode the late game plan
cards these cards are of course also
really good if you're going for green
tanks but these cards are like good in
general so even if you're not going for
green text these cards are most of the
time still worth it to pick up no matter
what strategy you're going for but
obviously if you are playing with green
text these are excellent and you should
keep them every single time also the
animal cards of course also really good
you can maybe even get more animals on
your card especially if the game goes
long longer and just the fact that this
has an animal tag if you have enough
green text energy just the animal attack
alone is worth something for you and
like we talked about if it is the last
generation and you still haven't managed
to play a bird yet you can just wait
until everyone has passed and then you
can play this card to just grieve one of
your opponents making sure that it
cannot build The Greenery in the extra
round very annoying the only other thing
about animals is that if you have no
animals you're sad but if you have
animals you're happy how many animals do
you have to have on your animal card for
it to be worth it as a rule you kinda
need like one Victory point on your
animal cards and then it's like okay but
really you want two or more if you have
two Victory point on any animal card I
don't care which one it is that is
definitely worth it and if you have some
nice Green Tech Synergy going on then
one victory ponderable card is plenty
because then the attack is useful for
all the purposes and yeah in case you
were wondering this is actually me
bringing a venusian animal to the dragon
roller coaster and they will learn a
Denmark I think exactly one out of seven
Legoland employees thought this is a
good idea now let's talk about something
that's really cool and that a lot of
people don't think about I think because
everyone likes the German amplifiers
everyone thinks they're so good and
usually yes they are but so are these
cards I think these cards are really
being slept on so if you're having a
good game and you're playing jovians
maybe six VP average for the Jovian
amplifier it's it's pretty fair I think
sometimes you'll get less sometimes you
get more 6 VP average is not far off if
you're having a good game this number
might even be generous but here's the
thing all the Joven amplifiers these
cars are really expensive iron mining
industry is 41 getting me currently need
20 water import from a Europa 25
terraforming enemy to 33 really
expensive so what I think a lot of
people fail to realize is that they're
only going for German amplifiers but the
green text this can give just as much
victory points and usually the cards are
a lot cheaper so let's actually compare
some of these now first of all all of
these numbers I'm coming up with here
they are not based in anything
scientific at all these are literally
just numbers I'm pulling out of my black
hole and these are simply numbers I come
up with based on my experience and my
thoughts and my feelings there's nothing
to do with science that being said we
should still do the math and some of
these because it's a lot of fun and also
it's quite eye-opening I think so
important nitrogen it comes with one TR
so that's one and then you get three
microbes you can put it on ants that's
one and a half and then you have two
animals that's another two points if you
put it on birds or something so even
without considering the plans that's
four and a half points so in the right
circumstance imported nitrogen could be
worth maybe seven points maybe five
pounds is even a bit low here but seven
points is also completely reasonable if
you can use the plants then we got a
large Convoy this card is also really
good if you have an animal card where an
animals are worth one per animal so if
we do the math the card comes with two
victory points then we have the water
that's one Victory point and then we
have the four animals so that's a total
of seven Victor points and two cards
just for this card so cards like these
and also stuff like Miranda this is why
it's really important to have at least
one cards where the animals are worth
one Victory Point per animal and worth
noting with the large Convoy in my
experience if you don't have one of
these cards if you only have one of the
enemy like pets where they don't give
half a point per animal then more often
than not it's actually better to just
take the five plants and build a
Greenery I think if you do take the four
animals from this card it really has to
be on fish or Predators or some other
cards that gives you one Victory Point
per animal a little bit of a fun combo
that I tried once or twice is like
actually using large Convoy on Martian
zoo and the idea here is then then the
four animals is actually equal to four
Mega credit production so is it good nah
I'm not sure but it's it's a bit fun so
you get the four animals which is kind
of like four Mega credit production on
the mushroom soup then you get two cards
which could be kind of nice in the early
game then you also get a water so you
can get even more cards it's just a
funny combo I just wanted to mention but
usually you should play the large Convoy
in the last generation or maybe a little
bit sooner if you want to get the last
water before that parameter closes
completely and then you should use it on
fish or something so really this combo
is like a classic but it's a classic a
good reason because if you're a fish and
large Convoy it's seven victory points
at the end of the game and also you get
two cards really good then we got vile
enhancers I think a lot of people really
don't appreciate how good this card is
but worth noting this card is only good
if you go for green tags and if you have
a lot of green tax energy going on if
you got no green tags of course this is
a bad card it's a waste of nine gold but
it really doesn't take much to get this
card worth it let's say you have fish in
your hand or you're planning to go for
green tags maybe you have like a logical
zone or just Advanced ecosystem is
plenty the thing about Valentine's is
it's so cheap it comes with a science
tag and just when you play the card just
then you get one plan but all of these
are like hidden bonuses it's easier to
understand at the end of the game or my
Jovian amplifier I won because they gave
me eight victory points but maybe while
enhancer gave you just as much you just
didn't think about it like all the plans
and all the extra animals and microbes
and stuff it really does add up it's a
very good card so I put on five Victor
points here for violent henses and to be
fair that's only if you're having a
really good game with a lot of Green
Tech Synergy you could also make an
argument for maybe three victory points
but then you also get like a lot of
plans maybe eight plans or something so
then we're back to five anyway right
because like we mentioned this card is
also a planned amplifier sort out I mean
you really can't underestimate how many
green texts there are especially if
you're going for green tags it also can
underestimate the value of the
flexibility sometimes you just really
need one plants or two plans so you can
build a Greenery then you could just
play decomposers and instead of taking
the microbe you can take the one plan
and then you can build a Greenery it's
perfect Herbie doors I just placed it on
four victory points this is a card where
every time you place a Greenery you get
an animal on this card worth like half a
point so to get to four victory points
you kind of need to have placed seven
greeneries after playing this card
because remember the card already comes
with one animal so this is probably only
happening if you have a lot of plant
production and stuff like this but even
if herbivores only gives you two victory
points it's probably still worth it
because remember the card costs three so
that's 15 total you're paying for this
in the last iteration that's still good
enough considering that a VP in the last
generation is eight so if you're getting
two for 15 that's a little better than 2
for 16 and on top of that you get to
decrease someone's plan production which
is also kind of nice then we got
venusian animals and this card is really
good this is only if you're playing with
the Venus expansion but I have had games
I'm not kidding where this card just
gave me like 20 victory points this card
can be really good if you've got a lot
of science tags and the thing is a lot
of the Science Tech you can just keep
and then you can play them after you
play venusian animals so kind of what
you do is the important Science Tech the
really high impact science I could just
play them as soon as possible Right but
a lot of the Science Tech it doesn't
really matter if you play them now or
you play them later so really you're
just holding a lot of science text in
your hand and then when you can finally
play the new scene animals then you can
play all of these sounds tags so if you
can manage to play it and you have a lot
of Science Tech this is amazing but the
thing is this is 18 Venus on the Venus
scale and that is really hard because
it's really hard to predict when your
opponents are actually going to
terraform Venus Venus is not one of the
three parameters you need to close the
game unless you play with this optional
rule that you also need Venus to close
the game but usually people don't do
this usually it's only water oxygen and
temperature so let's assume Venus is not
one of the global parameters you need to
close the game in that case it's so hard
to predict if people are actually going
to terraform Venus so likely you
actually have two terraform Venus a lot
yourself in order to play this card so
this is where this card gets a little
bit more fair it's not completely
overpowered because sometimes the 18
Venus is extremely hard but if it is 18
Venus and you got this and you've got a
lot of Science Tech go for it it's
amazing you'll get so much value then we
got an advanced ecosystem and like I
said if you have decomposers ecological
Zone easy that's five points right there
decomposers is really cheap but if
you're going for green text I don't
think it's out of the question that you
have like three Victory parts of this
card so that would be like nine microbes
you've gathered on this card and I think
that's entirely plausible and then we
got ecological Zone I just put five
Victor points I don't think that's
entirely unreasonable remember the cards
already comes with two tags so all you
need is to get another eight green tags
and then you're up to your five victory
points on this car I don't think that's
entirely out of the question so these
are like sort of the average values I
mean once again I don't have any science
at all to back this up but all I'm
saying is look at this amplifier over
here six victory points average and then
look at these cards over here it's
almost as good and these are a lot
cheaper so all I'm saying is do not
underestimate these Victory Point cards
on the Green Tech strategy these can be
just as impactful as the oven amplifiers
in fact let me show you a print screen
here of the game I had on the master
obviously this this was like a god game
so I'm getting like a lot of green text
energies and my points are quite crazy
here but this is just an example to show
you how much stuff you can actually get
so if you do the math on this this sets
up to 54 victory points I get just by
having stuff on top of my cards and okay
you could argue that security physics
complex is not really green text okay so
let's say 47 but that's like if you're
having a good Jovian amplifier game it's
probably not even 47 right and worth
noting this is on the mass app so this
is like only vendela and Prelude so if
you're playing like in real life it's
not unheard of it actually happens
pretty often that I have more than 100
victory points on top of my cards mainly
from Green tags but also stuff like
security fleets and floaters and stuff
like this and on the Mars app I've had
other games where I've gotten even more
points than this in green text but this
is just the only game like I had
available anyway it's not important the
point I'm trying to get across here is
that I think that green text can be just
as good as Joven amplifiers if not
better other cards you should be looking
for when you're playing for green tags
also of course these plant amplifiers
these cards can be really really good
and there's a little bit of synergy
going on especially with herbivores and
stuff so the more Greenery you get out
the more animals you get with this car
that's a little bit of synergy here but
there's also a little bit of
anti-synergy because the thing is when
you're going for green text oh I'm gonna
make Mars a better place it's got the
greens got the animals plants it's gonna
be great and you're kind of feel
inclined to like make this beautiful
Green Planet but really it's in your
best interest to let the game drag out
so the answer Synergy I'm talking about
here is maybe you don't want to put as
many greeneries to close the game as
normally because then you're actively
helping to close the game but I think
this is only like a minor consideration
you could think about it if oxygen is
the last pyramid as a close maybe it's
in my best interest to let the game drag
out a little bit but usually just play
the plants play the green tag you should
be fine you quality research we talked
about on the last generation I think
this card is amazing I might just play a
lot of colonies and slam this card get a
bunch of plain production but especially
when we're talking about Green Tech
Synergy look at what this card actually
gives you it gives you three green tags
it gives you an animal and it gives you
two microbes needle list to see if you
have a lot of Green Tech Synergy this
can also be a lot of victory points on
top of the plant production you're
getting then we got nitrogen-rich
asteroid and the thing is I think I've
always been high become insects but this
card is actually also really good this
card it might look pretty expensive but
it actually gives you three terraform
ratings so even if you don't have the
plan takes you need to fulfill the
requirement here just getting three
terraform rating and one plan production
for 31 that's a okay deal I mean it's
not great if you do the math on it a
terraform rating is worth eight so if
you're getting three of those as 24 and
then you play 34 for the card because
remember the cast costs three so that
leaves 10 mega credits that you're then
using to get one plan production it's
not that bad it's still better than
adaptive lesion cost nine but then the
card of three is as well so still two
better than adaptive lesion and the math
here there's even just for one plant
production if you actually get three
plant tags and you can get the full plan
production from this card that's
insanely good so these are also cars I
want to look out for when I play The
Green Tech Synergy and then of course we
have protected habitat always when we
are having plan production protected
habitat is really good it's also good
for the Green Tech strategy because when
you're playing this usually you have
microbes and animals and protected
habitats also prevent enemies from
removing those so protected habitat is
definitely a card I would value very
highly if I go for green text like look
at virus just removes two of your fish
that hurts man not to mention the action
cards that also can remove your animals
or your plants so we got predator or
ants or protected habitat it just really
feels good to play this card when you're
going for Green Tech so we talked a lot
about animals but don't sleep on
microbes either these can also be quite
impactful so there are two microcuts
where the microbes are worth half a
point per microbe and that ants and
venusian insects venusian insects is
only if you play with the Venus
expansion and once again 12 Venus that's
also pretty rough so it's not that often
you see this card but if you do get
these cards then in the mid game or the
late game it could be quite nice for you
to actually build a colony in insulator
so that you once or twice can put a lot
of microbes on these cards and can be
quite a lot of points and stars require
you to take a microbe from another the
card but it can be from one of your
opponents but even if the opponents do
not have a microbe to take you can still
take it from your bad micro card you can
just steal from tardigrades or ghg
producing bacteria some trash like this
another interesting card I also want to
put some attention to here is
sulfur-eating bacteria this card is
actually kind of cool it requires you to
have six percent Venus so it's not that
hard to get but sometimes it's a little
bit punishing a little bit annoying but
if you get this card and you also have
the insulators Colony out there then
it's actually kind of your own personal
Luna in a sense because if you think
about it all the microbes are worth
three Mega credits per micro so if you
have a colony here and you trade when
it's Max that's like six microbes so
that's 18 gold so if you can get this
down in the early game you're likely the
only one who will have microbes around
the table this early on and when that
happens then this is like your own
personal Luna but not only that it's
also completely uncontested you're the
only one who's going to fly here it's
just another little fun combo that I
play sometimes it feels really good when
you play it but if we are talking about
the mid to late game probably ends when
using insect is better with insulators
or it could also be that you have
extreme cold funcus this card is also
actually really nice in conjunction with
these two because the action of extreme
cold funkers that alone is like one free
Victory upon every generation that's
pretty good and also we got this sort of
new promo card here back to viral
research again if you have a lot of
science text this can actually give a
lot of stuff so this is pretty cool as
well it also gives you one card which is
nice so micro cards are really good if
you can get micros on this card but of
course if you cannot they're useless so
how to improve your chances of getting a
lot of Green Tech Synergy and get all
the combo pieces you need to make this
go absolutely insane once again card
draw is really nice it makes sense the
more cards you get the more cards you
will see the more green text you will
get and the more Synergy you can build
and once again try to make sure that the
game drags out a little bit because when
the game goes long in terms of
generation then you'll have more times
to collect all the microbes and all the
animals and all the free victory points
you get every generation and this one is
really important get any animal card
worth one Victory point animal I don't
care which it is but just get one and
the reason of course there's so many fix
in this game that just can give an
animal to another card so having one of
these animals worth one Victory Point
per animal is really important and also
keep all the good green tanks especially
the green text that could end up giving
you a lot of victory points is like
keeping a jovian amplifier sometimes
it's worth it even if it's in the early
game but it's not only these Victory
Point amplifiers it could be any of the
green text we talked about in this
chapter it like all of them could be
really good but of course like we talked
about in the first video if you pick up
a card in the early game and you're not
gonna use it until much later make sure
that your economy can handle it
otherwise you can really tank yourself
yeah that's pretty much it for this
episode thanks so much for watching as
always if you have anything you want to
debate with me in the comments if you
have any nice things I forgot about make
sure to write it I'll begin to discuss
any of this with you and I promise the
next video is gonna be shorter I promise